hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from round two of this
year's um sudat the Sevilla or the
Sevilla open 2024 it is an absolute
privilege to show you this game as we
featured meu a couple of times on the
channel for those of you who are not
familiar with her style I will include a
link first link in the description below
watch that game uh it's uh from the
Serbian women's league it was played
last year also an incredible attacking
game but this one uh it's um well there
were great attackers throughout chess
history I mean if we go really really
back you have you had Paul morphy you
had Anderson then maybe uh you know
going a little bit forward you had maybe
I know Rudolph Spielman you had V
mirovic then going more forward you had
mik tal then even more forward you had
Kasparov but um you know in modern times
okay you have dubo and other great
players uh but there was one that really
stood stood uh even above all of them
and that is the the true legend of
attacking chess okay mikal is you know
on the absolute top level he is of
course a legend but there is the man who
never goes back the the no reverse gear
Rashid ninov and me style uh if if I
have to pick one attacker it does
definitely remind me of of the great
Rashid ninov um so uh let's let's just
check out the game and for those of you
uh who don't appreciate uh being shown a
lot of variations maybe you don't have
time maybe you're very busy person I
will also include a really quick
overview of the game at the end of the
video maybe like a 1 minute just for you
to appreciate the moves uh but you know
if you have time I invite you to
appreciate the magic as well so let's
check it out uh 13y old women
Grandmaster meiu versus um a 31-year-old
Italian Grandmaster Andrea Stella uh
let's check it out so Pawn to E4 as it
is best by test we have Pawn to E6 the
French defense by Andre uh and now D4 we
have Pawn to D5 and now Knight to C3 we
have uh sorry Pawn to D5 Knight to C E3
and Knight to F6 going for the sort of a
classical variation of the French not
going into the VIN uh Pawn to E5 thein
variation advancing the pawn Knight fd7
and pawn to F4 we have Pawn to C5 very
principled attacking white strong Center
Knight to F3 and now Knight to C6 and
here Bishop to E3 so okay the bishop has
been developed you know that Queen is
coming to B6 to put pressure on that B2
Pawn But First Pawn to A6 you want to
stop the knight from coming to B5 and uh
here we have a fairly rare move now
there are over a thousand games with
Queen to D2 it is the main line but here
we have Knight to E2 and this is um less
than a less than a 100 games in the
database and it's been played by some
strong players like um topalo bid
morovich with knight2 also Fabiano
corana in last year's Norway chess
defeated Magnus Carlson with this move
so it has been played on the absolute
top level uh okay Queen B6 putting
pressure on White Center that's what you
do if you play the French you you attack
the B2 Pawn as well and you prepare to
undermine white strong center with Pawn
to F6 okay Queen C1 guarding B2 and now
Bishop to E7 we have Pawn to C3
strengthening the center here and just
castles King side and now in the game
that I mentioned where Carana defeated
Carlson in the uh 2023 Norway chess
karwana continued with the G3 and G3 is
one of the top recommended engine moves
but meu goes for Pawn to H4 so this is
the absolute move recommended by the
engine and it is still not a new
position so Pawn to F6 challenging white
strong Center Here pawn to H5 okay now
you have to stop Pawn to H6 or Pawn to
H6 by black and Rook to H3 she just uh
you know wants to bring everything into
the attack right away Rook to F7 setting
up a defense and now there is a Game
yordan Fan forz played against itm bakro
that ended in a draw where King to F2
was played and it is the top move
recommended by the engine but here meu
goes for for Rook to G3 just you know
straight up forward and it is now as of
move 14 that we have a completely new
game and okay Queen to A5 a pretty
standard idea you want to put pressure
on on White Center as the C Pawn is now
pinned so Bishop to D2 aligning the
bishop nicely with the queen we have
Queen back to C7 and now Queen to C2
preparing maybe to Castle Queen side but
also looking at Queen to G6 followed by
Queen captures on H6 uh but Andrea says
nope that's not a problem just Pawn to
B5 and indeed Queen to G6 looks very
scary uh but if you play the French of
course you are used to that it doesn't
matter if it looks scary you will play
it and I will just briefly show you what
queen to G6 does uh you just play B4 as
usual uh of course Queen to H6 will be
played but just B captures and C3 the
the G7 Pawn is nicely defended and after
let's say B captures Bishop to d8 and
now okay you want to prepare the
advancement of the H Pawn now comes
Knight E7 you kick away the queen and if
you want to continue attacking just
Knight to F5 now you uh defend G7 once
again you attack The Rook here and if
Rook to H3 trying H6 and maybe to give
up The Rook here not to give up as the
pawn cannot capture you want to play H6
captures and captures the idea is Knight
to H6 stopping the pawn attacking the
queen and once the queen comes to G6
even Knight to f8 further kicking the
queen back and I we just continue
playing the pawn to A5 Bishop can come
to A6 it's a very nice position for
black uh so that's the idea here it's
still of course Very Much playable for
white but black should be able to defend
so she just castles Queen side here uh
and now Pawn to F5 stopping any Queen to
G6 ideas and now you could continue this
you know some with some King to B1 move
or you could bring the Rook to G6 or you
could play D capes and C5 but not Meo
yulu she just goes forward Knight to G5
she says okay D6 Pawn is weak uh you
have to capture on G5 as your Rook is
also under attack here so there's 's no
question here the Knight must be
accepted H captures on G5 F captures on
G5 and now we have C captures on D4
already a suboptimal move uh but I often
say that it's easier to attack than it
is to defend you have to be an
incredibly strong player in order to
defend well under pressure and here
objectively best would just be to give
back material Knight C captures on E5
you destroy white strong Center Knight
captures and that's pretty much it if G6
you don't have to worry about anything
and if H6 you can just play G6 and
that's perfectly fine even if G6 Rook H6
uh and now if H6 the G6 Pawn will be
weak as it's attacked by the rook and by
the Knight but C captures on D4 was
played first and it seems like a move
you want to play of course you want to
open up the C file move the bishop put
the Rook on C8 to go after the white
king the problem is now after C captures
on D4 you no longer have this option of
eliminating white strong Center as the
queen on C7 is undefended so okay Knight
to B6 was played and now Pawn to G6
attacking The Rook here Rook to f8 and
of course Pawn to H6 just marching
forward no no funny business here and
okay Knight to C4 uh putting you know as
as many pieces as possible in front of
the white king now comes a nice calm
King to B1 you think it's a defensive
move but it's really an attacking move
with Pawn to F4 uh again maybe a bit uh
too optimistic you know slowly
developing with Bishop to D7 then
bringing the Rook to C8 should be the
way to go but Pawn to F4 was played idea
being that um The Rook now will come to
F5 you will develop the bishop and then
bring the other Rook to f8 claiming the
F5 for yourself now comes Bishop
captures on F4 G captures on H6 Bishop
captures on H6 and Rook to F5 and okay
uh you again blocked the queen you don't
have to worry about the attack you will
now get the other Rook into the game for
the moment you can't use the f8 square
but maybe you can just play bishop f8
and eliminated the bishop here uh so
here Rook to H3 uh what is the plan here
well you have to see uh the next move to
to understand we have Queen to A5 now
preparing some Knight to B4 ideas with
queen captures on A2 but just Queen to
C1 uh she wants to bring the queen into
the attack as as soon as possible and
now the problem is if you go Knight B4
and again it looks very scary there's
this simple Knight C3 and black has
nothing here there's no way to improve
the attack there's no way to actually
try anything here and it's just a much
better position for white it's a winning
position for white so instead Bishop to
D7 is played it is essential to bring
the bishop to E8 to help out with the
defense uh and now uh you could go for
something like Knight to F4 but she
prefers to keep the Knight here to be
able to bring it back to C3 to help out
with the defense of the A2 Pawn Now Pawn
to G4 uh forcing The Rook back or to you
know capture on F1 and since uh black is
already up a piece he decides to give up
The Rook for the bishop here so he will
be uh up you know he will have two
pieces for The Rook so Rook captures on
F1 Rook captures on F1 and now Bishop to
E8 this is a an essential move for black
if you allow Rook to F7 it's game over
there's no defense here uh for example
if uh you play something like Rook to C8
okay looks very scary uh just Rook F7
and Rook G7 check next it's Unstoppable
and that's pretty much it you you either
go under the mask of the bishop or here
uh face The Rook on the H file both is
uh terrible so instead Bishop E8 the the
only move for black and now uh Pawn to
G7 now uh Meo Yu is such a spectacular
attacker that I will show you a move
that uh she could have played but she
didn't as it's insufficient there is
this possibility of Queen G5 uh looks
flashy and you know it's it's a queen
sacrifice but of course black will not
capture and allow Checkmate uh if Queen
to G5 you can just counter it with a
nice Queen to B4 threatening Checkmate
and now you have to go back with the
queen so while impress iive doesn't
really do all that much you have to go
back and then comes Bishop captures on
G6 with check King A1 and black is back
in the game so she waits she plays Pawn
to G7 now the threat is of course Rook
to f8 check and it's game over now the
bishop is uh in the way here you have to
do something about it so Bishop to G6
with check now The Rook gains access to
the f8 square King to A1 and now Knight
to B4 again looks very scary is that
white king getting checkmated uh not
really but not with Knight to C3 Knight
to C3 uh would be terrible here if you
play Knight C3 you actually get
checkmated Knight C2 checking B1 you
face the the our good friend the bishop
on G6 now just Knight captures on D4
with check and once the king moves
Knight to B3 will be checkmated the pawn
cannot capture and the g the B1 square
is covered by the bishop so she plays
Pawn to A3 absolutely incredible that
such a defensive idea is even an option
with two knights queen and the bishop uh
you know lurking from the back uh but it
is possible however uh the attack will
no longer happen for for black or for
white because Knight to C2 check and now
what do you play here if you go King A2
it's just a repetition Knight B4 check
King A1 Knight C2 check King A2 Knight
B4 check it's a draw by three-fold
repetition but Meo Yu like Rashid on
that special day before he prepared
Queen captures on F6 she said nope I
don't feel like like U drawing this game
she played Queen captures and C2 just a
a queen sacrifice and it's not uh you
know not a correct one if you ask our
good friend the engine but we are not
asking our good friend the engine we are
asking Andrea Stella here and also you
guys so what is the idea behind the
queen sacrifice Bishop captures on C2
was played and now she played Rook H to
F3 with this terrible threat of Rook to
f8 check and now black is winning here
but here Andre had 3 minutes and 50
seconds on the clock to organize some
sort of a defense here it's not not easy
but you guys will get a chance just to
you know feel the position uh even allow
yourselves uh 3 minute and 50 seconds if
you want to you know get in Andrea's
shoes feel free to pause the video and
try to find the only move that wins for
black while I give you a couple of
seconds uh so uh for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations on
winning this position with black and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show the only move that wins is King to
H7 and it's uh it's such an ugly move to
make with all of this happening here uh
but it comes with a very straightforward
idea that Rook to f8 does not come with
check and now there doesn't seem to be a
good way for white to continue the
attack if you continue with your
standard Rook to f8 threatening G8 Queen
then just Bishop captures and now if
Rook captures you no longer control the
back Rank and now Queen to E1 check uh
how do you how do you prevent this if
you go King A2 then Queen to B1 is
Checkmate and if you block this let's
say Knight to C1 then there's this very
nasty King captures on H6 and now it
doesn't matter what you do because Queen
will capture on C1 with check even if
you bring a Queen into the game Queen
captures with check King A2 and queen to
B1 will be check mate so King to H7 uh
the absolute uh best way to play this
but it's still very unclear I mean even
if you play King to H7 and you find all
of this there's still uh moves you have
to calculate like like Rook H three how
do you defend against Rook H3 uh where
where is Black going from here well you
have to allow discoveries and play Pawn
to B4 but I
mean yeah with with four minutes on the
clock you just don't calculate that and
okay there's a there's another
possibility after Rook H2 F3 even if you
don't find King to H7 you can still just
say okay we go back Queen d8 the queen
covers the f8 square uh I'm just going
to defend this but the problem is Queen
now Rook to f8 will not be played now
comes Knight to F4 and the game just
continues but you have to calculate all
of this this with less than four minutes
on the clock so what actually happened
in the game uh after this Rook H2 F3
move uh is not Knight captures on A3 uh
the move you might expect because
although it looks uh incredibly
impressive just Rook to f8 check will
end the game I can even show it if you
guys don't believe me Bishop captures
Rook capture uh Rook captures with check
and now you either move the king and
allow G8 queen or you capture then G8 uh
G captures an f8 queen king H7 and queen
to G7 will be Checkmate however in the
game Bishop F3 was played and it's
actually a good practical decision uh
which is the third uh top move
recommended by the engine it it sort of
cuts off The Rook from having access to
the f8 square and the idea is okay I
give up the bishop and then I take on A3
and the white just falls apart but it it
doesn't really work G captures on F5 was
played now comes Bishop captures on A3
Knight captures also wouldn't make much
of a difference now just B captures on
A3 and it looks uh like we shouldn't be
able to do this Knight captures on A3
again uh you know facing all of these
nasty discoveries but now F captures on
E6 and now look at this where can the
black king go the F7 square has been
taken this is taken this is taken you
can go to H7 but then of course you know
that the Rooks are coming to the H file
but doesn't have doesn't black have some
sort of a Checkmate here Knight to C4
check was played we have King to B1 and
now King to H7 uh Sid stepping all of
the all of the Rook f8 check business
but now of course The Rook comes to the
H file Rook to H1 and again black starts
checking Queen to B4 with check King to
C1 Queen to B2 with check King D1 and
now fortunately there's no well
fortunately for meu there's no Queen D2
because the bishop covers that square so
Queen to B1 with check we have Bishop
back to C1 now with a discovery and
that's pretty much it uh you don't
really you don't really have a good move
here because if you go to if you go for
example to G6 then just G8 Queen with
check and once The Rook captures look at
this Rook to H6 with check King G7 and
Rook to F7 is Checkmate so unfortunately
you can't go uh down the board so after
this bishop to C1 check he had to go up
the board King to G8 but now look there
are no squares for the black king uh and
now Rook to G3 it is uh important to
defend the pawn or you could also
capture the pawn but that just runs into
a rook to G3 check King to f8 and now
Rook to h8 with check King E7 Rook to G7
with check King captures on E6 Rook to
H6 with check King to F5 and now look at
this Knight G3 Checkmate absolutely
incredible the bishop that is stopping
the queen from checkmating the white
king also prevents the king from coming
to F4 and it is Checkmate here so that's
why you can't go to G6 you cannot
capture on G7 you have to go to G8 uh
and now of course it's merely a matter
of defending the G7 pawn and now Rook to
h8 will be checkmated there's no
stopping this few more checks are
possible as they were made Knight to B2
check King to D2 Knight back to C4 check
but now King to E1 uh preventing any and
all checks from the Knight and also the
queen has no more checks you could give
one Queen to B4 check but then just King
F2 and then you're out of checks so here
Queen to B4 check was played but now
also Knight to C3 and he was in this
position and move 46 that Andre aella
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here there is no move
here whatever you play except something
like Queen captures on C3 but you don't
have enough material to do that Rook to
h8 is Checkmate on the next move and uh
that's pretty much it I mean uh
absolutely incredible game you know
worthy of the worthy of the Old Masters
uh you know just sacrificing the Knight
for the attack which okay a lot of
people would do even though maybe
objectively it's not the best but it's
best if you're an attacking player but
then giving up the queen in that
position uh I mean what what a move we
can even uh check it out one more time I
mean look at this your opponent is here
threatening all sorts of of uh you know
repetitions with with Knight B4 Knight
C2 Knight B4 Knight C2 Knight and you
just play Queen captures and C2 give up
the queen like this and then just
shatter the black King's defenses uh
even though objectively uh black is
winning but you have to find King to H7
which uh I mean with uh less than four
minutes on the clock it was um
impossible to do so yeah beautiful stuff
by me Yu very much looking forward to
seeing more of her attacking games uh
she she is an attacking player most of
her games are are wild like this so I'm
pretty sure this is a uh you know uh
only the first one uh will be showing
this year as you know it's only January
but already we we have started strong
and now for those of you who maybe uh
didn't have enough time to watch the
entire analysis I will just quickly go
through the game so it was a nice French
defense uh you know the classical
variation not going for the VIN this is
all pretty standard stuff played by you
know top Grand Masters now a fairly rare
move but it has been played you know
Carana defeated Carlson with it in the
2023 Norway chess she goes for H4 H5 you
know just brings The Rook into the game
Rook to G3 sets up an attack here uh and
then okay Queen C2 maybe threatening
Queen G6 but it wasn't played and then
okay Knight G5 we have a beautiful
Knight sacrifice here uh the Knight had
to be accepted we have captures captures
Knight B6 and now G6 so okay pawns
marching forward we have Knight C4 uh
opening of the f file and uh yeah after
the the queen was uh set up to to to
come to H6 uh some more moves were made
captures captures Bishop to E8 and now
Pawn to G7 and here is where the magic
happens Bishop to G6 check King A1 KN
before threatening mate so stopping it
with A3 incredible that the move is even
possible here but now after Knight to C2
she sacrifices the Queen Bishop captures
and now goes for the attack Rook to F3
Bishop to F5 cutting off The Rook from
going to f8 and now just Pawn captures
we have a capture on A3 captures
captures and the King hunt begins but
also the hunt on the black king begins
we have Knight F5 King B1 and now after
a few more moves were made uh and the
bishop covering D2 so you don't have
Checkmate uh black soon ran out of
checks Bishop to B1 also Bishop to C1
also comes with a discovery King to G8
and now Rook to G3 and there's no
stopping Rook to h8 Checkmate one more
check was given here after Queen B4
check Knight C3 and the game ended with
an Unstoppable mate coming on h8 so
that's s of the short version but if
you've only seen that and if you don't
believe it watch the longer version and
you will believe it uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoy the
brilliant stuff by Meo Yu I am uh you
know as usual I like in the previous
game that I've shown you by Meo Yu if
you haven't seen it first link in the
description below it's an absolute must
I'm you know privileged to to be able to
show you this and that uh also uh you
know one of the reasons that I'm glad
that this channel exists yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank Mark Henley Brennan Brian
pin Yun young Carol bot and Johan cence
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day and follow up with the
link in the description below first link
see you soon